cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com
is from NBC News
Standing Ovation for a Ukrainian who
fought with Nazis Sparks anger and an
apology in Canada I'd like to slow down
for you all and just rephrase that
headline NBC News oh how about Canadians
give Standing Ovation to you to Nazi
is that does that does that work for you
guys there you go Yaro slav hunka 98 was
recognized by lawmakers shortly after
Ukrainian President Vladimir zielinski
addressed the Canadian Parliament why
are they celebrating a Nazi
hard for me to understand they said that
they brought him there because he was a
Ukrainian and Canadian hero Canadian
hero because he's living in Canada so he
has you know residency there
but then very quickly said oh we
actually forgot to do a background check
and look him up which if you compare
this to the State of the Union anytime
they're like and tonight with us is Andy
know a journalist like someone has
vetted this person surely that's why
they are they didn't just walk into the
chamber and happen to take a seat right
like the idea that this person was not
researched beforehand either shows that
the entire Canadian government needs to
consider restaffing or that they were
aware of this but didn't understand the
implications oh they don't care I think
Canada does care I think they are just
uh not aware of any sort form of History
I think they are Nazis
you think all of Canada is not to use no
I think I think the people like Trudeau
they they they're Nazis they they learn
to to masquerade and shield their
eugenicists racist policies and cheer
for Nazis
so the big irony here is that the um the
Speaker of the House of Commons uh uh in
the Canadian Parliament so he's with the
the liberal party that's Trudeau's party
uh invited him and uh the the the Nazi
war veteran and
apparently all they had to hear was uh
he he served on a unit that that fought
the USS
USSR but didn't ask for their will on
fighting against them on behalf of who
fighting on behalf of the Nazis it was
an SS uh unit
and um it's I mean
you know I guess people should remember
that just a year and a half ago the
January 2022 when the Canadian Convoy
protests were happening uh the liberal
government Trudeau condemned them and
said that they were using Nazi symbolism
and not seeing injury and racism and
here they are
um now
um prime minister Trudeau next to
president zielinski in the entire
Parliament giving a standalone Standing
Ovation to not just an accused Nazi or
someone who's accused of being far-right
but an actual Nazi veteran yeah
he was a uh uh he served in the 14th
Waffen Grenadier division of the SS a
Nazi military unit whose crimes against
humanity during the Holocaust are well
documented
well there you go Canada I think it's
because they have no understanding of
History right right now Russia is the
big enemy and so anyone who fought
against Russia seems good but they have
very little understanding of actual
World War II history so they don't
understand that they do I I I'm not I'm
not willing to rule out that they do but
I just think a lot of it is someone said
oh this would be a great viral moment
where we stand up for this and they had
no idea because they're just not well
versed okay well you know I'm not going
to give them the benefit out here let's
let's we'll do this okay so they're in
Canada what can I say it's Canadian
right well let's talk about here in the
United States is the political uh what
what political faction is aligned with
the uh with the Canadian government
United States right it's progressives
right I'm not trying it's not a short
question in the United States Trudeau is
would be a progressive he would be
aligned with the left and leftist to a
great degree okay
um our leftists anti-Semitic
yes there's no that's not a question you
look at black lives matter and their
support or I should say many of these
prominent celebrities who who supported
black lives matter and also support
Farrakhan and the things he said
unsurprising you look at the article
from tablet magazine about when they
went to the women's March the the
organizers and were pushing anti-semitic
conspiracy theories unsurprising I just
got to be honest
I would not be surprised if eugenicist
anti-semites who share political views
happen to cheer foreign
are we supposed to argue here that they
use a different word for whatever it is
there okay fine I don't care call them
whatever you want they're the same thing
it's so funny to me that in a society
where everything is racist or
anti-semitic everybody uh can get
accused of this except for people who
are aligned with supporting Ukraine
including the actual soldiers themselves
oh yeah I mean yeah Russia goes the
other direction they try and claim that
everything happening is demossification
and I'm like that's stupid too like
Russia is not invading Ukraine because
there's Nazis there because they want
access to Crimea but you know Russia is
now clipping this thing of zelinski
being there and flying the actual
Affiliated Nazi and being like see we
told you we're here for denotification
it's also the story has also become a
big scandal in Poland because that
particular unit that that
um that elderly man uh was part of was
involved in a lot of slaughtering of a
lot of polls
yep
yeah
but they didn't know they didn't vet him
it's an accident that's the stupidest
lie I've ever heard I just get like how
could you even pass that off I mean it's
ridiculous I can't say whether or not
they're all anti-semitic and eugenesis
but they're definitely stupid well as I
have to say it's the banality of evil or
it's malicious evil how many of them are
actually maliciously anti-semitic
eugenicists and are probably a few but
they're smart enough to get a bunch of
morons to clap and cheer for a Nazi so
all you need to understand about how
stupid these people are how dangerous
they are is that they don't know or care
who they are clapping and cheering for
it's like when Joe Biden said treat him
out a shot of the pressure and the crack
goes yeah and they're all clapping and
cheering and you're like this is crazy
Joe Biden goes on stage and says better
calf care and everyone says clapping and
cheering they don't know what he said uh
they just know they're supposed to clap
and so they did
it's frustrating to me that
um
often quite uh educated people are
so so they're very good at recognizing
propaganda from Russia and good for them
for that and calling it out but the
propaganda that is coming out from
Ukraine it's like they just there's no
scrutiny of any of it and there's so
much propaganda this whole
uh you know there's well one turning a
blind eye to the Contemporary
connections to Nazi organizing in
Ukraine that's completely now no longer
an issue to liberals around the world
um and then Ukraine now being reframed
us as a Bastion of liberal and
Progressive values when it's that's not
reality of what the what that country is
in Northern Society
no I think it's all political theater I
think so much of this is just people not
willing to question Ukraine in any any
uh instance at all and so you can't call
it any propaganda because you're not
allowed to doubt Ukraine's motives in
anything you're not even allowed to have
any kind of doubt you're supposed to
submit entirely to supporting Ukraine
and never question any of it I mean look
how much money we have shipped over to
Ukraine why because we're just supposed
to and those who do speak out are then
smeared as uh somehow fans of Russia or
fans of
um uh Putin I mean yeah the the smear
tactics just causes people to become
fearful
I think so much of it is just a lack of
understanding of of geopolitical History
right they have no idea what the ties
are you know they don't know what
happened to Crimea there's they don't
know what to say they just know right
now it's good to have your blue and
yellow flag out and to agree with
whatever Biden says and therefore
whatever zielinski says yes they want a
simple story of villains and heroes
who's a good uh good guy and who's a bad
guy and then it leads them to do stupid
mistakes I think it was a genuine
mistake like what happened in the
Canadian Parliament oh a Ukrainian World
War II here about in great let's invite
him you know and they stop looking and I
think that's also a testament to the
to the I assume whoever vetted him is
fairly Young working out in a stat
position for this elected official and
they think oh yeah I read most of that
headline and I know what I'm talking
about I don't think it matters I don't
think it matters at all that whether
it's a mistake or not that's just it's
at this point in the culture war in this
point in the war with with uh with
Russia and Eastern Europe all that
matters is what they do if we sit around
saying like well you know that was a
mistake every single time they scream
and cheer for Nazis it's like okay
you're gonna be you're gonna be giving
the benefit of the doubt as of to them
the entire way it's like we're sitting
in a car with these people and they're
driving full speed pedal to the metal
foot to the floor right towards a cliff
and we're like well but hold on a minute
they're probably gonna turn right
they're not gonna drive off the cliff
they wouldn't do that and then every
single time it's
so at this point I'm just like I don't
care what what they thought they were
doing this is what they do it's who they
are that's it so all I got all I can say
is yes Canadian Parliament gave a
standing ovation to a Nazi yeah but as I
said I don't care why they did it they
did it Ukraine has become so good at
playing the West like if it'll like
they're you know one of their
spokespersons now is this transgender
American anymore though oh that changed
I think they got rid of that person
because of uh the trans spokesperson
threatened to kill anyone you know
something like that was that what
happened
I can look it up but there's like a
video where okay well either was or
until very recently this transgender
American spokesperson for Ukrainian
military who doesn't even speak
Ukrainian
um obviously that's you know playing two
Sentiments of the the left in the United
States colony of the United States and
then when Solinski went to the UN giving
a speech and talking about climate
change
all right but listen Ukraine is a colony
of the United States that's why an
American English-speaking leftist is the
one talking about what's going on it
doesn't matter who is in Ukraine the
NATO and the West don't care and when
you learn that the U.S has been funding
the businesses and everything in Ukraine
might as well consider Ukraine colony of
the United States just call it I I don't
care for this this word play that we
have in modern politics right where it's
just like well you know oh not really we
don't call it that are we at war with
Russia yes
in in all Form and Function but is it
declared when was the last time the US
declared a war against anybody we just
go and do it so you've got U.S citizens
volunteering with U.S weapons with U.S
training with uh with with U.S backed
artillery and intelligence and it's like
but it's Ukraine that's at War yeah
Russia doesn't think so because
practically it's the stupidest thing
I've ever heard and this is where we're
currently at thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time